and I'll be the judge she's the dumbest  person to ever play the lottery and I'll  say this right now we go to play the  Mega Millions do you remember it was a  billion dollars everybody was talking  about it you get to choose your own  numbers and this [ __ ] afterwards I said  which numbers did she choose she shows  me her paper and she chose 1 11 22 33 44  55 Powerball  66. why is that crazy you can choose any  number why is it crazy the odds the odds  are all the same though it is the odds  are no matter what the numbers are you  know for them to be in a sequence the  odds are way greater see I told you yeah  you're both idiot no I do one two three  four five six yeah that's what I do yeah  I do it doesn't every time no it doesn't  matter it's all  you see the odds are different if you do  random numbers